I'm about to show you a clip from MSNBC
here is Andrea Mitchell our final topic
they found some cocaine at the White
House and the Machine is going out of
its way to make sure we will never know
who that cokehead is and turning to some
breaking news we have just learned that
a formal lab has confirmed the suspicion
that that white powdery substance found
in the west wing on Sunday was in fact
positive for cocaine the discovery led
to a brief evacuation of the White House
Sunday night joining us now is NBC White
House correspondent Mike memley so Mike
where do things stand now this is so
unusual you and I have covered the White
House for years I can't even
fathom anything like this having been
found before In The West Wing and I go
back to the 70s at the White House so
this is pretty pretty wild
it's absolutely extraordinary Andrea and
this new conclusive test confirms what
had been the preliminary field test
conducted by D.C fire Personnel who were
called in on Sunday night after the
discovery of this suspicious substance
by a uniformed officer in the Secret
Service that was conducting a routine
patrol of the White House and so to
recap on the developments from that
we've been reporting on yesterday this
was found we understand in a highly
trafficked common area of the West Wing
it's an area where individuals
especially visitors individuals who may
be coming for for instance a private
tour might have been asked to leave some
of their personal belongings before
heading into more sensitive areas of the
West Wing which of course includes the
presidents the vice president's office
some of the most senior officials
offices as well as the Press team and a
number of deputies
we'll never know
we'll never know who is doing cocaine at
the White House Hunter Biden was just
there uh two or three days before we've
got a little video of Hunter look at
this look at this
oh my goodness
I probably smoke more parmesan cheese
than anyone
the guy's smoking parmesan cheese I mean
guys just like joking aside for a second
the way the media is running around
telling us we are never gonna know
within days somehow January 6 they can
facially ID everybody now they're
telling us that in a highly trafficked
common area in the White House they
found cocaine apparently they found a
bag by the way it wasn't just like
cocaine like on the desk
fingerprints all the people that have to
be id'd to go in Barnes It's just so
bizarre I I mean I don't even know what
to say
well I think that was the Babylon B meme
which had uh a picture of uh you know
the bag with it says property of Hunter
Biden on the front and the headline is
we uh they they can't figure out okay so
the I mean that's it it's I mean anybody
who saw the balcony scene anybody that's
been around somebody that's done cocaine
I mean it's obvious that that that's
what honors do let me do my conspiracy
version of this Viva tell me what you
think of this I think they clearly know
it's hunter or at least at the very
least they know who it is but let's go
on the Assumption for a second it's
Hunter and they want you to know that
they will not release the info meaning
like they want you they want the media
to immediately say we'll never figure it
out because they want you to know they
have Democrat privilege and they can get
away with any effing thing imaginable
Dave it's it's the I got a ding on that
one how about that it's the persuasion
just plant that's plant to see that they
know is so uh incredible that no one
will believe it but I gotta say if you
go back and watch that video look at
Jill Biden's face it's almost like she
says darling or honey to Joe and look
over my shoulder something is going on
behind me that shouldn't be she doesn't
look happy and it's wild but let's let's
yeah here we go darling look over my
shoulder look at that tell me that she
didn't just say something darling and
look over what's going on behind me I
know something's going on that that's my
body language reading